[Music]
joining us now with more reaction to
tonight's opening monologue Judicial
Watch president tom Fitton Fox News
contributor Sarah Carter Fox News legal
analyst Gregg Jarrett Tom let me start
with you we still have missing 33,000
emails but and this is a couple of
hundred but there was classified
information
I know Judicial Watch works very hard
Freedom of Information Act what did you
find
well it's a new batch of emails from the
email that James Comey is FBI recovered
the from the emails that Hillary Clinton
tried to delete or hide those 33,000 so
this is the batch of Hillary Clinton and
awards didn't what anyone to see and
they include 10 classified emails about
Middle Eastern policy communications
with Anthony Blair and top officials at
the State Department about Middle
Eastern peace and its further indication
and further demonstration of the massive
violation of national security laws
related to the mishandled and classified
information that Hillary Clinton
knowingly engaged in you know we're
spending all this time and money
targeting Donald Trump on really nothing
and in the meantime a Hillary Clinton
has walked away scot-free despite time
after time of new information coming out
showing that she engaged in criminal
conduct this Justice Department has got
to decide whether they're gonna let
James Comey have the last word of
whether Hillary Clinton did anything
wrong or not Gregg Jarrett yeah I know
you've been writing a book and your
office your office is two doors down
from mine I would like you to tell the
title but then I want you we are back
again 18 you I feel like I got a collage
education from you 18 USC 793 and now
it's applicable to James Comey tonight
yet absolutely as the name of the book
is called the Russia hoax the illicit
scheme to clear Hillary Clinton who
framed Donald Trump and it goes through
all of this one of the things that's
very interesting here that we're
learning about today is the Comey
appears to have committed a felony by
misleading Congress a material omission
because Comey was asked about leaking
the material to Daniel Richmond he
didn't disclose that Richmond was an FBI
employee he didn't disclose that he also
gave it to Patrick Fitzgerald and by the
way the FBI has gone to both of those
gentlemen's offices to do what's called
a spillage
clean up to contain the wrongful leaked
by Comey and the other thing in commis
comments that you played tonight he
seems to be overlooking the fact that he
stole government documents 18 USC 641
the moment he took those presidential
memos out of the FBI building and took
them home doesn't matter if it's in a
safe that's an unauthorized place he was
stealing government documents which is a
felony all four of us have been way
ahead of the curve when I was joking
tonight that it sounds like with a
couple of questions Anderson Cooper
asked James Comey might you might have
actually been watching the show and not
telling anybody because they have been
on the wrong path for a long time over
there but you know Sarah we're waiting
to struck page memos I want to get your
comments on that and also on this
because Andrew McCabe is in trouble Jim
Comey is in trouble
struck and Paige are in trouble that
Clintons are in Hillary Clinton is in
trouble I mean this goes to the and I do
believe clapper
and Brennan I want to find out what they
knew when they knew it and then they're
leaking raw intelligence and
surveillance and I'm asked if this is
we're just at the tip of the iceberg and
it's now happening yeah we are at the
tip of the iceberg Shawn because we know
that the Inspector General has another
report coming out in May that report
will detail how the FBI handled
mishandled the Clinton investigation and
let's go to the struck and page text
messages why is it that Congress has to
make threats you know threats of
contempt in order to get these documents
they have been looking at these
documents for some time now turn them
over to Congress let the American people
see what they have what the Department
of Justice has I know I've repeatedly
called the Department of Justice today
I've received no call back no
information whatsoever as to why they
have not turned these over yet I know
the congressional members say they're
expecting to get them tomorrow there's
also a lot of concern here with Comey
you know Comey can try to backtrack and
make these excuses but he did take FBI
property out of the FBI and another
issue that Comey is really going to have
to deal with is like if he believed that
his discussions with the president were
uncomfortable
were obstruction why didn't he tell
Congress this when he spoke to them on
May 3rd why go the runaround why the
leaking it's it's again we're back to
lying by omission here it's sort of like
with the FISA Court application they
never they knew that they didn't verify
it and they knew that they handed it
over something that was more than just
maybe politically tainted it was an
opposition party candidate I want to ask
all of you the same question we'll start
with Tom who based on where we are
tonight we know now Comey is lawyer DUP
who else should be lawyered up tonight
Tom Finn well Andrew McCabe obviously
there's an anger there's referral
pending now with the US Attorney for the
District of Columbia that could come at
any time mr. Comey I would stop giving
interviews if I were mr. Comey at this
point the IG is investigating him and we
already know from the Justice League and
prosecute the prosecutors are waiting
call me and McCabe faces significant
criminal liability right Greg German
it's coming and he knows he's in trouble
because he hired the two people he
leaked government documents to so that
he could invoke the attorney-client
privilege and clam up it was a
Machiavellian move he makes jig or
Hoover look like a boy scout well
attorney-client privilege doesn't seem
to be the thing that people are
respecting nowadays but I think you know
Lisa Paige and Peter struck as well and
and others and even Loretta Lynch
there's a Bruce or there's gonna be a
lot of names in the upcoming reports and
a lot of people that I think will be
luring up all right amazing work